despite being cozy and comfy at the crib
it's curly time go sub G Q I'm Gerald
and I'm back for round two to show you
my at home essentials presents in so you
know it's kind of a piece of my uniform
but a piece of myself is my aides hat
that I pretty much wear every day
especially when I'm away from home from
the bay it's kind of just like a thing
that you know ties me to home and
reminds me where I'm from I'll probably
own over a hundred eight hats this is at
UM spy probably a few months and still
got some life left I had one that I was
like wearing forever I let it get real
real real dingy and dirty and then I got
a ton of crisp options and you know
making that decision on which one to
wear these days it's not as easy as it
looks the biggest essential community of
my Studios I'm very very very blessed
and fortunate to have an at home studio
this is the upstate of my studio so it
has like my plaques on COBE Jersey some
arcade games
you know I survived up here but then
downstairs in the real studio that's
right go to completely work in my
lock-in and focus like this room as I
get the ear break gets your mind off it
for a second to come back fresh and then
I go downstairs and it's like there's
nothing but words down there my whole
studio is lit up with hue lights I'll
switch the colors of them depending on
the song I'm working on depending on the
vibe I'm in I don't know what I would be
doing with all this time if I didn't
have my studio I'd go crazy it's
obviously an outlet a place to express
myself and to pour myself into something
I'm usually in a studio with you know
producers and our guy this was just me
alone in my studio so all of a sudden it
was like damn like I'm gonna just make
whatever I want to use this time to
freely explore creatively and break the
rules because why not
a big at home essential it's just nice
scented candles
the big little ABBA Santa just filled up
the room with a real nice scent I didn't
know but like a nice scented candle
you're only supposed to burn for what
like 20 minutes and then that fills the
room with the scent for you know an hour
or two or whatever but you know I like
the vibe of having like a ton of candles
lit you know so so a big at home
essential you know in a way I've spent a
lot of time there in quarantine there's
been reading you know sometimes it's
hard with our busy life kids it gets
hard to like to sit down and focus but
for me reading over quarantine has been
a practice of you know remembering the
focus to slow down until I read a post
office Charles Bukowski I'm reading a
farewell to arms right now are you
telling away Chuck Palahniuk choked and
then probably the favorite thing I read
over coin semen was acid for the
children it's a memoir about fleet for
my hot chili peppers like I love the Red
Hot Chili Peppers of Japan but like I
didn't I got to know a lot more about
sleeve is you know upbringing his youth
is you know it's whole backstory yeah I
love Fitzgerald I would like like
classic like timeless like authors that
are you know that iconic and I feel like
going back they really transport you to
a different time in place reading is
been a big thing over coin seeing and
like a great way to just like pass the
time until at home music is you know as
essential as anything is in my life and
listening to music in the right way so I
have Marshall speakers all around the
house they're statically pleasing they
look like old amps and the sound quality
is great if I listen to music every
single day it's one of the first things
when I wake up something else tears make
my coffee music I immediately I've been
building a record collection for a long
time but there's a part about putting a
record on it's like yeah at the click of
a button on your phone you can have any
song ever made anywhere but there's I go
there's a respect you put on the process
take that record out you put the record
on it's an experience it's not just
background music you know it's an act of
like really appreciating the music
itself but yeah I mean there's a few
records a Radiohead
Ben's Mac Dre xenia lamp
nirvana unplugged which is one of the
greatest I love Supreme John Coltrane
those it's a lot of times lately and
then one of my favorite albums of all
time
Midnight Marauders Tribe Called Quest
Nina Simone can listen to a lot of Nana
a pretty eclectic range but you know
just some of the stuff I'm into music is
something that just makes a home feel
like a home I shouldn't believe that
it's atmosphere so obviously a big
essential you know we've all been in the
house you know getting dressed it's not
what it used to be so sweat suits or you
know let's go to this one is don't fire
upon a supreme anytime I find something
I really like
I usually just buy backups you know when
you find something that you really like
this like guy I mean love look so I
enjoyed watch this wait I like like your
snobby own blog something dry and crisp
and citrusy some friends of mine are
like really in the one who are staying
with me at the house so just like trying
all different kinds so it's just like
it's old like part of the night they can
cook your dinner and you have a nice
wine with it how often do we open a new
bottle of wine a little depends on the
night coffee isn't essential I love
coffee I can't look at my phone I can't
talk to anybody I can't think before
I've had a cup of coffee that's just
like this don't bother me and so I've
had my coffee sometimes I'll just do
espresso sometimes drip pour over coffee
sometimes of French press I like Pete's
coffee I made pizzas from the Bay
I just think coffees delicious and it's
the whole again it's a process of like
you know making a French press or you
know the smell of espresso
I usually just turn your black maybe
some cream a - not a splash how many
cups of coffee do I have a day that
number I'd not like to say but I like
four to five cups a day way more than I
should be having in the backyard I'd
like a treadmill some waves we jokingly
call it Jerry's gymnasium for me running
is very meditative and obviously you
know you have to stay active and find
ways to exercise my treadmill is like
that's where I go to meditate and just
like find that call me yeah I like
running to film scores
I love the Dark Knight score I love
Brooklyn for a dream that scores well
that favors getting thirty minutes like
three miles to eight minutes in like per
day it just feels good after you after
you get that done you gotta finally to
stay healthy during quarantine I think a
lot of us have had the opportunity to
inwardly reflect and decide like what we
want to change or learn or evolve into
I've always wanted to learn how to play
piano and learn how to sing and I've
spent a lot of time working with a
teacher and a coach I mean I started
just by like my ear like I would put a
record on and like just start to play to
it figure out with kids and fun scale
but like spinning the time to really
like work on that and learn how to play
piano the piano is like a even as a
piece of furniture it's essential to
like at home I mean it makes my home
feel like a home pre quarantine we were
doing in jazz night at Jerry's you know
like a little get-together like we'd all
like cook up dinner and then just play
in the Sun jazz and like you know drink
some wine you know smoking so it's just
kind of like a thing that ties everybody
together anyway it's an upright it's an
old one I didn't want to give something
like brand-new and fancy and clean I
think there's like rustic quality so I
can old piano and it just reminds me of
my grandma's house y'all sit at the
piano every single day sometimes we'll
sit down for five minutes sometimes I'm
there for two hours it's like gonna
trance music is something I tend to get
lost in you know it can be that way in
the studio I'll blink in eight hours and
past
thanks again GQ I appreciate the
opportunity much love to you guys those
are my essentials
[Music]